[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one
you were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus there's so much
of you that i feel like i saw when i was
watching the movie like buzz's
relationship with socks it couldn't help
but think of like you and your
relationship with your dog dodger
and your voice is so perfectly his
i was talking to the filmmakers and they
were saying that your voice work on snow
piercer actually really impressed them
oh really yeah that's what it was and i
feel like as buzz fans we've heard tim
allen's version patrick warburton's
version in the cartoon how did you craft
buzz's voice well i mean do you
certainly have to use
tim allen as the blueprint the character
itself is
supposed to be what the toy was based
off of so so you'd be a fool to not use
tim's work as a blueprint uh aside from
just the fact that he was
fantastic in the role um so so he
certainly was in my mind i think the
first session i was just doing a
shameless tim allen impression um
because again it's it's big shoes to
fill and
it's scary to try and think about
uh coloring outside the lines but uh but
eventually you able to find some
nuance that you can make that's just
your own you killed it did you listen to
anything like would you listen to tim's
voice back or i mean i watched all the
light year movies or the the toy story
movies uh you know not only had i seen
them already but certainly before every
session you watch them again and even
just every pixar movie because
you know when you're in the booth and
you you're trying to
bring a certain level of truth and
authenticity to delivery um
and then you'd listen to it back and it
would almost feel
flat at times and you realize
this is the one
string you can play on as your voice you
have more freedom to add
more color
you know he's put a little extra sauce
on it so so eventually by the second or
third session you realize you know what
i'm just going to give you everything
i'm going to do some way up here i'm
going to do some down here and up here
and you guys figure it out later but but
you realize that you're allowed to take
more risk well you killed it sauce
worked um it's also wild because i know
as a kid it was your dream to be a
disney animator
and i remember you posted a picture on
mother's day and you had like a mickey
mouse on your shirt and i was like he
totally manifested this because i was
reading that you were giving the
animators pep talk or you were giving
people pep talks you were in the
animation dailies
yeah the angus was so sweet he let me
sit in on one of the the animation
sessions where
you know you have all these amazing
animators and angus will kind of each
animator has a little section to work on
and then angus gives notes but but these
notes are
i mean they're acting notes it's it's
literally you know well i think buzz
needs to you know look quicker and then
i mean i've said in a few interviews so
far pixar is so good at eyeball acting
you know in
non-animated films
your eyes don't lie you know your eyes
it's where you can tell whether or not
you're thinking um and pixar movies i've
seen moments where the character you
know the eyes will
flick left and right as it's searching
for thought
giving incredible depth and authenticity
that's a choice by an animator these
animators are
true artists and and watching the the
meticulous attention to detail that goes
into it was was just really fascinating
and i was a little jealous yeah it's so
cool though that you spent so much of
your time like learning all this stuff
because you're such a fan i know
it's super cool because i also saw that
you met with nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory so i wanted to know would you
ever play buzz lightyear in a live
action
god wouldn't that be good wouldn't that
be cool wouldn't that be fun would you
oh my god that gets a little meta though
doesn't matter that we start really
overlapping i'm not sure i think if it
if i think if it went live action they
almost have to
kind of wipe the slate clean and start
fresh maybe get a brand new person in
there you want to you wouldn't want to
do it i mean look if they want to come
to me i probably wouldn't say no i
wouldn't be able to but but i think i
understand enough to know that it might
need some fresh blood all right well i
would love to see you in the role i feel
like you are so much buzz lightyear and
what really hit home for me is someone
who like struggles with perfectionism
with sort of this message that it's like
okay to make a mistake and i'm like when
did we decide that it's like not okay to
make mistakes right like it's so crazy
what um how do you handle making
mistakes and what advice do you have to
people when it comes to overcoming that
i mean i'm sure i'm like everyone i beat
myself up a little bit but i think you
know if you are able to
uh move past the mistake i think that's
where there's the most opportunity for
growth so
so once you actually have a good
experience with that kind of shift and
that kind of evolution i think it opens
your eyes to the realization that the
mistakes are what make us human and it's
not about whether or not we make the
mistakes it's about how we move through
them and and what we take away from them
and how we become better people as a
result of them yeah did you feel that
sort of when you were like saying some
of buzz's lines oh sure i mean there's a
lot of buzz's story that resonates with
me that i can identify with so
absolutely yeah
on rottentomatoes.com we are having a
pixar showdown right now where we're
having our users vote for their favorite
pixar film so aside from light year
which is obviously like number one um
what do you think should have the top
spot the incredibles why it's a perfect
movie it's just a perfect movie i mean
i'm a huge
craig t nelson fan
i i i just think it's it's just a
perfectly balanced structured movie
everything is just
everything from from the directorial
choices i think brad bird is a genius um
to me it's to me it's a perfect movie
and it's it's easily my favorite pixar
movie i love that um the last thing i
wanted to ask you is i feel like
when you look at like your body of work
whether it's like fantastic four or
captain america or lightyear you're sort
of always like drawn cursed to these
heroic roles
what do you think what do you think
that's about like why do you think
you're drawn to all these roles and how
do you tap into sort of that like heroic
side that all of us like have inside of
us well it's not the number they did
those are the roles that i just you know
it wasn't by design that you just say i
only want to play heroes you know it's
just kind of you know that's that's what
i end up playing um
i'm not sure i mean i even a hero is
full of flaws i mean that's that's what
makes them interesting to watch you know
i think without flaw i think julianne
moore once said the audience doesn't
come to see you they come to see
themselves so so even in the heroes you
play they have to have flaw they have to
have things that
make them human that's why
we choose to watch them so um again it's
not that i'm choosing to play heroes it
just so happens to be that way but i
would argue that even the heroes i play
are still
incredibly human ready captain light you
ready as i'll ever be commander
hawthorne this is exciting a new
adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you
come right back to us
to infinity and beyond oh so kiki
congratulations on this movie i mean
what an epic space adventure it made me
want to ask you like
would you guys be down to go to space
and how do you think you would fare as
like a space ranger
totally down for space
not so sure i'm signing up for space
ranger i'm there like as the tourist
watching out the window enjoying
somebody's guiding me through it that's
my experience yes i need to be 100
secured they need to have done at least
a thousand trips
on mine and absolutely no on the space
ranger i'm with izzy on the whole like
it's too much space in the space yeah
space so i'm good inside of something
within that it's hilarious i also feel
like we're not too far from like being
taurus in space 100 so wild to think
about um it's so cool that you guys play
granddaughter and grandmother in this
like
did you get to listen to each other's
recordings or exchange notes
before you guys started i didn't i don't
i don't know if anybody else did i
didn't but um i definitely got to see
you know images of izzy and what that
would look like and i saw alicia and i
knew what the story was so the entirety
of the experience was really thinking
about like everything is going forward
this is who this this is our hero you
know
love i love i mean there's so many
takeaways and i think that's the biggest
thing for me too with izzy character and
alicia and just all of what that means
in this in this story is that this is
the future that feeling was very much so
apparent and then i was gonna say only
an animation would she be able to be my
grandmama
every time you say that out loud
because i'm like of course in animation
yeah that's what you can do right right
do you guys feel like family now because
i feel it it feels like that like just
sitting across from you guys i mean i
feel that way just loving her as an
entertainer in the industry and seeing
everything that she's been able to do i
feel like yes my girl when i say i'm
like
you know what i'm saying so um yeah i
mean i feel like that way regardless so
glad we finally got to do something
together now we need to also do a live
action exactly that's exactly right
drama comedy come on drama let's get the
girls to cry a little yes yes
let's get a light year live action oh
we're ready would you be down for that
yes that'd be amazing just not in actual
space though for sure yes we're still
guests there you go but you guys kill it
because you say one of the most famous
catchphrases in all pixar to infinity
and beyond how many times did you
practice saying that
i don't even know if i said it out loud
the first time when i read it i was like
no way that i'm really gonna get to say
that and then
when we were in the booth and i said it
for the first time i lost my mind i
genuinely was
like started jumping up and down and i
was like so excited i'm
positive that take is not usable
that was like just something i was so
excited about you know it's amazing i
think that um
yeah i don't think you realize
how much things have impacted you until
you do it so same thing for me as soon
as i said to infinity and beyond in the
recording studio i'm like yo
i just said to infinity and beyond so
then it hits you like what that really
means to you uh you know what i mean so
it's just crazy what does it mean to you
i think it means what a lot of what
uzo's been saying uh is that it's the
future it's that it's the beyond it's
that there's more there's no sky's not
the limit especially with the character
like izzy hawthorne and alicia hawthorne
being able to be a part of lightyear
that's what it means to infinity and
beyond we all deserve to shine and be
seen in this way and in this life yeah
and what used to be big maybe isn't so
big anymore now you're saying to
infinity and beyond yeah both of your
careers are just it's it's really been
such a joy to watch um another joy for
me to watch in this movie though was
obviously the themes and pixar like i
can't not walk into a pixar movie and
not cry um as i've struggled with
perfectionism a lot in my life and i
feel like making mistakes
so beautifully
reminded that it's okay to do what did
that mean to you guys
the theme of this film i think the
themes that theme is very powerful i
think it just it was a movie that was
creating space space for those mistakes
to live that those mistakes aren't
setbacks that they aren't interruptions
to
everything that you ever strive for it's
actually an opportunity for you to
progress for you to learn something that
you know to give yourself a little room
and a little a little bit of um the same
grace that you might give another person
um
and that
i don't even know if any there's such a
thing as mistakes really even as much as
it's just a course that was already sort
of set for you and
i love that this movie was tackling that
i love that this movie chose to have
buzz even confront
life and his own you know
our own we can sometimes be our own
worst enemy oh my gosh you know that
metaphor was incredible yeah and i love
how that's something that we saw that
izzy learned from her grandmother from
alicia's character because that's what
alicia always was to buzz since the
beginning you know he started to spend
so much time away from her life passing
him by but at the end of the day when he
you know meets izzy again he's met with
all those same messages that izzy was
instilled with which is that give
yourself grace you know that's what
being a leader is because when you don't
acknowledge okay you know what i made a
mistake i can move forward then you stop
yourself from moving forward which is
what happens with buzz his inability to
say it's okay that he made a mistake had
him trapped in just vicious cycle right
and he said space i'm like that was the
actual space in the movie if you think
about it which i love right just mind
blowing levels levels levels before i
leave on rottentomatoes.com we are um
hosting a pixar showdown so aside from
light year which pixar film do you think
should be number one
are y'all kidding me that
then i went to finding nemo in my head
wait a second
for me because i'm just always on that
mental health gag which i mean i think
it's like
i'm on a lot of things but like i'm
screaming to the rooftops inside out
that one just for me i mean especially
when i saw it like i mean
i just felt like
i remember being in the theater with
like i had some kids with me but i felt
like it was for me and i'm like i needed
this
it was so good so inside out for me
i'm
now you know what i'm actually calling
an audible because i said up before you
know which one i also loved seoul
oh yes it was great
it was great that one
that was deep deep
they go
deep i mean it goes they're not afraid
of going there though which is the thing
and that's great i mean we should have
known when they said let's do hamlet but
remiss it we should have known then that
they was just going awful all the way
and what about you well i thought this
was gonna be like a fun boot camp
workout
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the harpoons tycho i love
seeing you lend your talents to like
marvel star wars and now pixar would you
ever want to direct a pixar film like
what would a taiko attitude teachers i'd
love to like i would love to be involved
in a pixar film or direct one but i'm
just not sure
if my brain
could work that way that takes a long
time for these guys to make these films
and you know i was one of the first well
the first writer in moana and i was
just watching the process of that and
seeing how long that took to make that
film it was years
and i don't know if i've got that in me
i just don't know if i would be focused
i think i'd probably just
i'd just get distracted by something
else and
yeah i'm the same way i'm like oh a
butterfly let me start a new project now
that's so funny but i mean you have so
much going on and you've done so much
incredible voice work like you're korg
and thor your ig-11 and star wars your
mo in this and i feel like all the rules
are so cosmic like what fascinates you
about space and would you ever want to
go to space
i do want to go to space i'm a bit
scared of i mean like kiki's character
i think i'm probably
too freaked out at the prospect of
drifting off like george clooney into
the
and
it's just that idea of being that lonely
and out there with no one else around us
it's just very scary to me but i do love
space and i love watching space movies
it's actually one of my favorite genres
and um
yeah that's uh
yeah i love space i love it
what do you do to get into state tyco
because like before i do an interview
i'll like meditate and stuff before you
do voice work like what are you doing
what are you listening to or are you
doing funny yeah i was mentioning the
voice characters before because i forgot
about like
i think yeah ig-11
korg
this guy
here's the
the funny thing is that they're
basically just my normal accent i didn't
really
i could have put on an american accent i
didn't really try that hard i was just
being myself but with a different pitch
talks up here like this and this is uh
moe like this
and that says ig-11
really there's no is there a difference
um
it's a really great way of working
though like and to get into that stuff i
don't i
i think i just
it's just it's very different it's very
different to live action acting or
acting with your whole body and your
face and everything because
you actually forget about your voice a
lot when you're acting and you're just
like concerned like how do i look what
am i doing remember you're moving and
stuff and when you're in the booth just
doing a character's voice it's all
you've got and so like sometimes i'd be
like
you know we're doing like multiple takes
on just a simple line and i didn't
realize that i wasn't quite there's so
many ways just to to say words and to
emote and to like you know get different
meanings out of words and it's just a
whole
new different way of working
yeah there's only so many ways you can
say like a writing utensil you know
without giving anything away yeah
exactly
pen pen pen
pen
pen
as you know what i did actually have to
say that line quite a lot
anyone want a pen anyone want a pen you
want a pen want a pen
well you nailed it every single time
tyka um but like i said i can't wait for
the world to see you in this pixar film
and actually at ron tomatoes.com we're
hosting this pixar showdown on our
website where users get to vote for
their favorite pixar film
so i wanted to know aside from light
year which
our film do you think should i pop stop
up up up up up
why
it's for me it's the it's the most
emotional film
of theirs that i've seen it's the one
that speaks to me the most um i think
the themes in it are
you know they're very clear and
relatable
but also the idea of also like having
the main character as an elderly
man
it's you never see that no one takes a
risk but no one like makes a movie about
an old person and you know that for me
was like one of the things that made me
think these guys are really like they're
not afraid of doing films like this and
also one of the greatest things it's not
a spoiler because i hope everyone has
seen up but
the idea that in order for him to move
forward in his life and for him to
actually fly he has to get rid of all of
that stuff that he's been holding on to
all of his memories and all of those two
chairs are the last things that he has
to get rid of so the house can fly and
there's such a great metaphor for life
for now we should be
living i love it and every pixar movie
makes you aside from like make you cry
it really i feel like it's just like
a lesson to adults like hey this is what
you forgot as a kid remember this and
the one for light year the theme in
light year just hit me so hard cause i'm
like a recovering perfectionist and so i
was wondering what did the theme mean to
you and how do you handle making
mistakes taika um i've really beat
myself up about mistakes i've you know
like i've
i've made a whole thing about you know
putting myself out as like a confident
person who's like good at everything and
i'm good at pretty much everything i do
but
maybe the problem with
with that is the you know when i do make
a mistake um
yeah
i can't let it go and i'll like yeah
that's the kind this kind of stuff that
will keep me up at night so what was it
like for you to say that those lines is
mo like it's okay to make mistakes like
did did you feel it sort of visceral
viscerally well yeah i mean i did like
you know there's some stuff in there and
we there's obviously with every film now
you're doing a lot of different lines
that don't make it into the film but
there was a little piece
you know which was about like
just
who he was and you know why he was part
of the space rangers and
um
and with that character in particular it
was about you know he was like living at
home with his mother and he was like
just wanting to prove to her that he
could do something and his
and he you know she was encouraging him
but he wanted to really like follow
through this time and actually finish
something and like see it through to the
end for a change and you know i think
we've all been there especially myself
when i was younger in my early 20s i was
you know one of those people was like
i've just got to finish one project
because i start 100 projects but i never
finish any of them and um yeah now it's
the opposite i've started 100 projects
and i have to finish them all
commission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
one there was a big swelling too i think
i need a bed oh no please record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle you're not vomiting
i couldn't help but think how you're
here
you know voicing the bad guy in
lightyear and your son josh you know
it's thanos and the avengers what do you
think it is about the brolins that make
them such good bad guys
well i don't know that i'm such a good
bad guy yet uh
that i haven't heard any
any feedback really yet and i haven't
seen a polished
film yet i've seen the film but not
really finished with all the music and
everything
uh
josh
i've said it before i wouldn't want to
be up against him in a bar fight
because he is a tough guy
and me i i i think i am but i'm not sure
if i could pull through like he you know
he's a krav maga expert and uh
jiu jitsu and all of that stuff plus
you've seen his physique for the movie
so yeah anyway i have a i have a lot to
uh
uh uh work toward
emanating you know my son
you know
that was so sweet i love that do you
guys ever exchange like notes and tips
and stuff when it comes to this stuff uh
no no i'm i'm
every once in a while we're getting a
good conversation and i will try to give
him some wisdom which he doesn't buy at
all
he's his own man that's for sure
that's so funny um did you
ever talk to andrew stanton who is an ep
on this movie and he actually voiced
zerg and toy story too and i was
wondering if you guys had any
conversations on bringing that voice to
life or how did you sort of make this
voice your own um
i walked in not being allowed to know
what zerg really was other than
what i lit what little i'd seen and what
i asked and uh
i didn't really even have the dialogue i
didn't have any preparation at all
because they didn't want me to
gab about it you know let even friends
they didn't want me to tell anything
about what i was doing
and even right now uh i'm somewhat
limited about what i can say about zerg
but
anyway i go into this recording session
and angus mclean the director
is
on a video screen with
the writer and the producer and
uh several technical people
and um
we start to work through the dialogue
and he starts to correct me and it
wasn't really until the second session
that i began to correct things from the
first session and begin to understand
what i was doing
well i can't wait for you to see it
because you are absolutely phenomenal in
it and like when you see it visually i
feel like you're gonna i just it's
unbelievable really truly and your voice
just really um
i don't know it makes you feel things
viscerally like i know you narrated
sweet tooth for netflix what is it that
you james like love about voice work
well uh
40
at least 40 i said 40 years before but
it was 40 tapes
sample tapes that i did for agents to be
submitted for
for whatever voice work never got a job
all these years wow
so last year or a year and a half ago
robert downey and susan downey call up
and say
we want you to narrate our series yeah
right which is the the voiceover uh i
guess it's narration
um
and i didn't really know
what they meant but uh i would i
because of um the shutdown
they brought the studio to my house they
had a screen a box at all and i was
literally all alone with earphones to
warner brothers
i could see this the dialogue and the
guys working with me and i never left
the house that whole last season so
anyway that started my first job wow a
voiceover and the pixar guys heard it
and i here i am you know and the rest is
history isn't that crazy yeah and it's
funny because over the years
i would uh you're not getting an
elevator and somebody said what floor do
you want you know you know how somebody
pushes the button for you
and i um
i'd say uh fifth floor and they turn
around and say well i thought that
sounded like you
so evidently over the years i thought
well there's something recognizable
about my voice not to me but right to
other people no it is it's incredible i
don't know what it must be like for for
you to wake up to it every day
i'm so happy that this like short
journey in voiceover work has brought
you to this iconic film like here yeah
uh you know one of the most famous catch
phrases in pixar is to infinity and
beyond what does that phrase mean to you
and and this theme the theme of this
film is so much about moving past
mistakes and you've had such a wonderful
illustrious career so also you know what
does to infinity and beyond mean to you
and what advice do you have to people
it's different
infinity means there there is no end
right
so maybe there's uh
to this franchise there is infinity and
beyond there is no ant last picture
but this picture is so different than
the toy stories
that it's going to grab a whole
it's going to add a whole different
audience right
i i believe and you know it's another
billion dollar
picture for them yeah
and uh it is a visit to space kind of to
answer your question it is a visit to
space it's for you know that where they
end up is 4.2
million light years away that's a that's
a trip and it takes a while to get there
and back if you want to come back from
it i would
um
and uh
i i'm i'm a pilot now for 50 years so
when i fly i plan to come right back and
going out into space is not personally
my thing except for a visitor let's say
around the earth i'll look see and then
come back home but uh four years to mars
not my cup of tea
and and what advice did you have for
people um to overcome mistakes uh get to
work go to school
get up there and try and do what you
think or know you can't do because you
can burn through anything
and it may hurt i was the least guy that
should have become an actor
i couldn't give a book report i couldn't
stand up in front i still have
trouble you know at a microphone with an
audience out there
but i literally i went to school and uh
uh
it was terribly painful and it finally
worked through i didn't die afterwards
i come back next week i'm still alive
same horrible feeling happened i burnt
through it i don't think it matters what
you
try
you can burn through it and be
successful
you think you can't but don't believe it
and read this book called psycho
cybernetics which talks all about
burning through
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
i love socks so much i always love
the sort of ancillary pixar character
but this one is this one's like a little
more special i think oh my god oh that's
nice of you i'm sure you feel that way
too are you ready for like a million
people to ask you to say
i do it with my kids every day anyways
and so no worries
oh my god that's so amazing did you go
method for this at all peter like did
you take any characteristics or robots
or or cats specifically to tap into this
voice
the you know i don't know if it's method
but there's definitely
voice keys for me i remember
uh frank oz the guy who did like rover
and fozzie he came to our art school one
time and he talked about voice keys
and i had never heard of that but like
you know for like um every character
that he had there was like a word like
for burton ernie he played ernie no he
played bert and um he would say gray
gray was the word for him to get into
the voice of burton he would go gray and
then he would just talk like that and uh
um it's not i don't know if that's
method but for socks there were these
two phrases for me in terms of trying to
find yeah the robot side and then his
friendly side i was like the idea of
the the robot side was not that he was
robot but there was like a military
aspect of him that like was want to get
the job done and like he would have
these protocols and and describing
probabilities and stuff that was very
like intellectual sort of like a spock
sort of logic person and uh but my key
to that was
uh saying yes captain and so before a
line i would just go yes captain the
probability of this thing would be you
know 38 or whatever but then for the
friend side of it like i would be
tapping into my relationship with my
kids or my wife or my brother and or my
dog and just like you know there's this
like you know like um uh it was like the
key was uh like hey buzz yeah so like it
would be hey buzz you want a snack cake
and so there would be these two
sides that i i that when you get the
pages because you wouldn't get these
pages beforehand you would get them
immediately in front of you and then you
would kind of scour through the lines
and trying to
play the sides of
of of those two weird keys i feel like i
said too much but that's what that's
that was the game no i could listen to
this all day that's so fascinating i
love that you shared that with me and
you bring up something really
interesting that there is this duality
to socks he he is like a complex
character in a way where it sounds like
you approached him like two different
characters like bruce wayne and batman
yeah yeah totally i never thought about
it like that but yeah
but it was like you know i love sci-fi
movies where they have these kind of
androids that are always like butlers
you know in space but then you know when
angus first pitched this stuff like he
was he's like psychological help for
buzz like wait what what the hell
happened to buzz that he would need
psychological help and you know those
concepts were
crazy what's so interesting that you
bring up
that exact thing is when i talked to
angus yesterday and i asked where the
inspiration for socks came from he was
talking about how it came from these
toys from the 80s and how like all these
kids would you know like the jumping dog
that we would always see on the ground
either at the mall or like a flea market
um
and what i thought was interesting is
that they started you guys started
working on light year years ago
and when you think about what we've all
been through in the last couple years
and how now everyone has an emotional
support animal it really is fascinating
how that all sort of lined up did you do
anything to tap into your more
compassionate side um for that part of
socks
to tap into it like i'm a sat naz like
there there is no tapping in it's just
there and so for me
usually it's like if you know when
you know
there were there were versions of the
movie that were you know they they put
socks to a lot of things and i remember
the different emotional aspects where
angus would start pitching like okay
this is the scene we're like oh really
okay and then like you would get to this
place of like you know like i don't want
to say goodbye or i don't want to do
these things and
i don't know if it was those they're
easy jumps to like to try to find it
just because i'm a ham
i love that i'm the same way um well
something that wasn't an easy job was
going to space for socks um it was fun
for me to picture like what an actual
cat would be like in space
which is just kind of hilarious if you
think about it um did working on this
make you want to potentially go to space
like do you think you would make a good
space ranger is that something that
interests you
look i i
the you know that the child in me would
love to be a spanish space ranger but
you know as much as i've gone to
disneyland there are some rides that i
cannot do over there like i get so
motion sick on space mountain so if
there was any real like trip to space
like i would be like you know like
where's the bathroom you know like i
would just be
terrible but um um once in space i'm
sure that it would be fun but boy
uh i would love to but i know there are
limits
yeah that's so funny you're like moe on
space mountain
exactly um so at rotten tomatoes we're
actually hosting this pixar showdown
right now on our website
where fans get to vote for the number
one pixar movie so i wanted to know
aside from light year which pixar film
do you think should have that top spot i
have the top spot
boy it's really hard i would say the
original toy story for me that was the
first one i was in art school when i saw
it and it totally changed my career path
and made me want to come here and so
that one for me would be
number one it's so good toy story 2 is
number one for me but your career at
pixar is so fascinating peter
like you um you did voice work on
ratatouille you directed uh the good
dinosaur and i know um you're gonna be
directing elemental
what about the elemental film made you
want to go back to the directing chair
um it was it all stemmed off of
uh um
thanking my parents honestly that was
uh it was there was this you know
um
party that i went to where you know they
weren't like you know
you worked at pixar let's you know
celebrate you and uh um i didn't want to
do it just because i'm i they don't need
to celebrate anything like that and then
but
at the time my brother was like you
should do it for mom and dad and i was
like yeah and then so we brought my
parents there and i remember having this
silly speech about like working in
cartoons and everything but when i saw
my parents in this crowd like you know i
got very emotional and i was just like
my brother and i would not be here if it
wasn't for these sacrifices that my mom
and dad had made
and so
so that idea of trying to thank our
parents
was
what where this movie sort of
has its little seed
and that's and so it's been i've never
done anything this personal before and
so i if there was anything bringing me
to this it was that was the north star
and then from there you know all these
other relationships in in our lives
started to fuel it
but that would be the seed i think to
infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
i know when people walk out of this
they're gonna just be thinking socks
like
where did the idea
for socks come from was it from a pet
from a toy and is there a reference to a
famous
90s white house pet in there
oh yeah i think that that's sort of a
bleak but the um
the socks
uh for for legal reasons i don't think i
can discuss which toys it's based on but
i will say that jumping dog that would
always jump around gucci uh
no
pucci is a separate toy but there were
several it's an amalgam of several sits
there in the 80s flips over yes yes is
that that was that i was thinking more
of the knockoff poochie then i didn't i
didn't i didn't have the fancy real
poochie anyway so uh we wanted to be a
little bit like an amalgam of several
toys and also
for whatever reason in the 80s there was
this big boon for animatronic animals as
children's entertainment and i never
really understood that fascination
because it never fooled me uh but i was
like how hard those robotic animals
tried and so there's something
inherently goofy and funny to me about
an a cat that does not
look like a cat
it looks like a cat but it's not fooling
anybody uh and that's very charming to
me so but also like how wild after the
last couple years that we've all lived
through where everyone like is getting
an emotional support yeah yeah like
right like wasn't that just so don't you
just love when the when it happened
everything happens like that it is kind
of crazy um yeah so bravo to that it was
so amazing i can't wait for the world to
meet socks um also can't wait for every
90s kid to see this i'm like such a 90s
kid it's a movie that andy sees it makes
him want to go buy a buzz lightyear toy
what did you guys do to make this movie
feel more 90s and are there any easter
eggs
for being 90s i mean it's it's it's
almost a little bit more 80s yeah i
think i think what we did was just uh
but no there's some 90s right yes i
don't i don't know i don't think we have
uh i think we just tried to make it um
a an amalgam of that kind of
70s and 80s sci-fi
actioneer
to have that sense of fun that we wanted
the audience to have like a
i think the word thrill ride is kind of
it's an odd thing to say often that's
fun is something you say when you don't
have something nice to say about a movie
that was fun but like that's what we
were going for we wanted it to be
something that had this sense of
narrative propulsion that would take the
the audience on the journey and they
would enjoy it as a group and that it
would be this funded space adventure
yeah no and i totally got the 80s like
sort of sci-finess too it was more like
i just pictured myself with my sega
genesis going yeah yeah yeah and stuff
like that where i was like wow that was
so famous i think that's just um
things we think are funny from the age
that we are so happy i love it it's so
good i was also reading um that you guys
sent some of the pixar artists to nasa
yeah
i love the research that goes behind
these things and when we think of the
the first men that stepped on the moon
we so often think of neil armstrong and
no one talks about buzz aldrin and i
wanted to know like was that was buzz a
point of inspiration like for you guys
at all or
or for the artist for this buzz
specifically no but definitely the the
current batch of astronauts yeah i mean
speaking with with tom marshburn and and
his colleagues over at um
at johnson it was it was pretty
exceptional like who they are how they
carry themselves how they look at things
the way they approach problems their
gratitude for the team that gets them up
there and keeps them alive it's just
they're really an inspirational bunch of
men and women and that had a huge
influence on us and they're really good
at the press day i mean tom was very
eager
he was used to yeah used to reading off
a teleprompter i tell you that uh yeah
probably easier to depress when you're
not trying to also not bob around yeah
no that was
one thing was neat when we were talking
to him on the space station as i said
could you uh could you turn upside down
and just talk to us is that weird he's
like
yeah i can do it but they don't like us
to i mean that it can be disorienting
for the he was very very considerate of
us but he just and then he did it then
he did it and so he's like this doesn't
feel any different to me and it's like
yeah of course it's it's it's
weightlessness but it's funny that there
are certain ways we orient yeah to make
other people comfortable uh which is why
we're sitting right side up right
same i wanted to do this upside down but
they were like they went they're like
they didn't know
nasa prefer we didn't do that
um galen you just said something that
stuck out to me um
you said like it was fascinating to see
like how they work as a team at nasa
right and how these other people get
other
the astronauts ready and it very much
made me love and think of the characters
that you guys made for this movie like
they all work as a team and as someone
who has struggled with perfectionism so
much i never thought i've always loved
buzz but i never thought i would ever
see myself in buzz which like meant so
much to me how did you decide to so
beautifully and politely remind everyone
that making mistakes is okay
i think it was aspirational for
ourselves
me most i mean i've always related to
buzz because of his
particular specificity and his uh laser
focus on
on doing the right thing but the um
buzz's journey and the spirit of
collaboration is actually a very
selfishly personal one like the the time
jumps in the movie are a metaphor for
making a movie at pixar so when we make
a movie i was noticing we'd go four or
five years and then i would go home and
then everything seemed slightly
different people were a little older and
i was like huh this is weird um and so
that that kind of time jump is is what
inspired the movie
wow yeah and this is your feature film
yeah yeah yeah sorry
five and a half years later yeah and i
know you've been there for a long time
yeah thank you very much thank you and
congrats on casting the perfect buzz
thank you yeah let's talk about chris
for a second i i read that you guys said
you wanted someone who had the perfect
combination of drama and comedy what
from chris's body of work were you like
this is our guy
oh there's there's a bunch i think i
mean obviously captain america and doing
that that man at a time and um and and
the trueness of that the authenticity
that he brought to that that was
definitely a part of it but like for me
to be perfectly honest watching snow
piercer yeah there was something about
like the
how
if you just even listen to it without
watching him how much he vocally
expresses
conflict and and dilemma and pain that i
just thought oh this man's got the
breath we need that yeah i think snow
piercer was i agree that one was really
um transformative that's interesting
we've never talked about it yeah we
talked about that but i really love that
yeah so but it was interesting uh how
much
he
embodies the role part of it is that you
have such a an iconic character and you
have such an iconic voice in the toy and
when we're making the character from a
side character the main character
there's certain expectations you have
and then of course if you're casting a
baritone that limits it tremendously
but
but
chris was we we met with chris and he
was such a joy and we pitched the movie
he totally got it and it was just
wonderful to have that kind of
partnership on this film and it was just
it was super fun because often he was
our first audience right when we would
show him stuff and he'd be he would be
really excited about it and you could
kind of see if he was having questions
they're like okay well
maybe we need to smooth something out
yeah that's so cool what a great focus
yeah because i know it was his dream to
be a disney animator ever since he's a
kid so it really is just such a total
manifestation and bringing together and
he brought that enthusiasm to every
recording session he was just like a
little kid it was it was really
hilarious it was great yeah yeah yeah
i'm the best i have to ask you guys
before i leave so on rottentomatoes.com
currently we're having a pixar showdown
where users get to vote for the number
one pixar you only get one pixar movie
so it's sort of bracket style oh yeah so
aside from lightning of course which is
our own movie i have to say is my
favorite currently and i'm not just
saying that because i'm like sitting
across from you like
sure no i promise aside from like your
school what's your favorite movie what
is the number who should have the top
spot pixar movie it's so hard it is so
hard well there's elements you know
there's yeah but go ahead well i i've
only ever seen one pixar movie as an
audience member oh wow only toy
and so it's really hard for me to see it
as a movie
and so
i didn't work
on inside out and it was able to see
that one fresher than most so that one
means a lot to me because i i could
experience it but in general i i i
incredibles was probably as a as an
individual contributor the one i had
maybe the most fun on uh and i worked on
that for three and a half years but uh
we're getting the hook what about you
what do you think what's your favorite
pixar movie
save the two might be radically
it's really really good yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah why i'm a sucker for
visuals and i just think it's gratitude
is really sumptuous yeah it's just
beautiful and i think we try to actually
we we talked a lot about ratatouille and
what we liked visually about ratatouille
and what we could bring bring into this
film in terms of that that stitched
together cohesive look of ratatouille
that we were trying to capture here so
very inspirational for us but
you